welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today, Dr
Heidi Toric, who's an assistant professor
of international history,
the University of British Columbia. And the
nonresident fellow at the German Marshall
Fund of the United States as well as the Canadian
global affairs institute. Uh, great to talk
to you today. Appreciate your time. Thanks
for having me. So let's talk a little bit
maybe just to establish some of the terms
we're going to be using when we talk about
public opinion and published opinion and show
how we should be thinking about those two
concepts and how they differ. What are we
talking about? Published opinion in public
opinion.
So this is one of the really basic distinctions
that I make in the book that I've just published
is so often political or economic elites think
that what's published in a newspaper or today
what's said on TV is public opinion. What
everybody thinks. And what I would say instead
is that's actually published opinion, which
is what a certain set of journalists and other
people have produced. Uh, public opinion by
contrast and sort of aggregate of all the
things that people think in a population.
And we have to be careful not to think that
the American public has one public opinion.
So part of what I talk about is how this often
gets misunderstood and leaders actually think
that something is public opinion that is actually
published.
It seems that this is a distinction that goes
back, I mean, I guess maybe to telegraphy
right? Uh, uh, in the sense that there was
a point at which you as an individual existing
in the world, we're hearing about what people
believed from those people. It really depended
on the conversations that you were having
with the so called public. And at a certain
point it became possible to put some other
sort of opinion in the hands of those who
have access to the means of communication
and communicate more quickly than an individual
might be able to with someone else. Is that
sort of the origins of when public and published
opinion started to separate?
I mean, newspapers as a genre. So printed
forms of Newsday begin much earlier, so really
in the 16th century, but they don't become
very dominant until the 19th century. So it's
really with industrialization that we see
the rise of the mass urban newspaper. And
those are moments that are very tied to things
like telegraphy where you can send news across
the Atlantic so much faster. And there are
particular newspapers or especially news agencies,
firms that emerge that are basically just
doing the job of collecting news from around
the world and sending it through telegraphy
for other newspapers to print. So a lot of
what I've written about is the power of these
news agency. So some of them still exist today,
like Reuters or the Associated Press. And
they really emerged in the mid 19th century
about the same time as telegraphy. And they
become really important bottlenecks of global
news. There are very few newspapers that have
foreign correspondents or anything else, but
most of the people who are reading newspapers
didn't really know what news agencies were.
So you start to see sort of industrial division
of labor where just a few companies are really
controlling the source of national and international
news that the vast majority of people who
are buying newspapers will read.
Yeah, I guess that's, that's a good point.
So I guess what I was not in thinking of newspapers
as predating telegraphy, the distribution
of those newspapers were still happening much
more slowly. It depended on someone bringing
the newspaper and, but you're absolutely right
that that does of course predate telegraphy
to go to the early 20th century. Uh, and the,
uh, use of some of these mass communication
methods, published opinion to use published
opinion to influence public opinion. Maybe
in Germany we could even talk about what are
some of the important sort of data points
or milestones in the way that this was used
to governments advantage.
Yeah. So, so this really changes quite substantially
over the late 19th and first half of the 20th
century. So at first there are lots of newspapers,
but it takes until even the 1890s when scholars
start to say how to a moment we should know
how many newspapers there are and how many
people are reading them on whether this intersects
with voting patterns at all. So it begins
really with jazz things like press clippings.
So you'll see if you go into archives, and
this is in Germany, but also in other countries,
just collections of press clippings about
certain themes. And that gets taken to kind
of proxy for public opinion. So we've seen
what the conservative newspaper says and what
the Liberal newspaper says and the more marks
newspaper and that's taken to just represent
public opinion. So that is that government
elites try to intervene and what newspapers
are publishing thinking that will then influence
public opinion.
And what we see then off to world war one,
particularly as the growth of much more interest
and more rigorous studies of public opinion.
Uh, partly because journalists get uncomfortable
with the fact that they've been so involved
with propaganda during World War One, they
and the newly emerged and journalism studies
or newspaper study start to reflect on what's
the actual relationship between these two
things. Can we measure it more statistically?
Can we do surveys to try to understand what
people actually think once they've read the
newspaper? And that by the sort of mid 20th
century starts to emerge into public opinion
surveys, things like Gallup, the sorts of
techniques that we are much more used to today.
What change was there after the initial sort
of era we're talking about in the early 20th
century that maybe didn't serve as a reset,
but that was sort of the next major shift
in how public opinion and published opinion
need to be considered and evaluated separate
separately. Was it a technological change
that took place in shifted us into the next
phase or was it something else in terms of
the relationships between some of these wire
services and governments or you know something
else altogether? Yes, and one of the things
that that's
really important, you're right, as developments
of new technology, and one of the things I
talk about in this book is that we often mistakenly
see technology as something you sort of autonomous,
but actually you can see with the Germans
there they become really interested in information,
particularly around 1900 and they start to
see it as a way to exert global power. I mean
it's a bit like they see inflammation not
as soft power but as a way of achieving hard
power. And one of the things they do at the
same time, the German government for example,
is to invest in a new technology that's known
as Wireless Telegraphy. So it's basically
sending telegrams at through the Aa using
electrical signals and the German government
subsidizes private companies do research and
development into this new technology, really
driven by this political vision that you should
be able to spread news around the world and
Bypass Telegraphy and submarine cables that
many Germans fear of control by the British.
So you can see as this technology develops
over the first few decades of the 20th century
and accelerated by what happens during World
War One, um, that this technology becomes
something that we call a one to many technologies.
That means you have one wireless tower and
then it's sending too many, many wireless
devices. And that wasn't how it was originally
conceived as a technology. It was conceived
like calligraphy, which was one cable here
and in cable that, and so what you can show
is, okay, this technology is developing because
of political and economic visions of news
should be, and eventually that will morph
into spoken radio as well.
Can you talk a little bit about how the increased
restriction within Germany, uh, in exactly
the ways that you talk about in sort of the
post World War One era actually allowed or,
or maybe even ease the way in which the Nazi
regime was able to take over the communications
within the country?
Yeah, I mean there's, there's so much terrible
irony too. A lot of the history that I talk
about because obviously after World War One
Germany becomes a democracy, but it's a pretty
feeble one. There were lots of political uprisings
both on the far left and on the far right.
And this is also the moment when spoken radio
emerges early 1920s and one bureaucrat hands,
Plato is charged with figuring out how should
we regulate this industry. And he thinks radio
is a great opportunity. It's a way that we
can bring together this population. We can
give people who are tired and attainment,
classical music, we can uplift them through
educational programs. But we need to have
some state supervision of what's going on
here because we don't want to have too much
news because news might inspire more political
uprisings. And as the Weimar Republic goes
on, political unrest continues.
There will be multiple radio reforms pushed
by people like read or who say, okay, we actually
need more state supervision over this content
because it's a way to actually preserve democracy
because we can stop news from sewing further
divisions in the population. So a couple of
radio reforms. And what that means is that
essentially state supervision of content.
By the time the Nazis come to power. So the
ironically, these measures that were meant
to save democracy, they mean that when the
Nazis come to power, immediately they have
control of radio content. So there's this
moment in August of 1933 about seven months
after the Nazis come to power where Joseph
Goebbels, the propaganda minister says the
Nazis couldn't have come to power and uh,
held it like they did without the airplane
and the radio. And airplane was something
that made Hitless in very modern cause. He
flies around and gives lots of speeches so
that helps them come to power. But it's the
radio that helps the Nazis really secure that
position and establish an authoritarian dictatorship.
It seems that there's this interesting analogy
between the use of communications technology
for uh, propagandizing and the possibility
that any technology can also be intercepted
or manipulated. So like from the it side,
there's always this idea that every time there's
a new technology with it come new ways of
possibly interfering hacking, uh, whatever
the case may be. Even back to like using drums
in Africa to communicate from one village
to another, whether or not some rival village
was coming, those drum signals could also
be intercepted and manipulate it in the sort
of same way. It seems that with every new
communication technology came ways in which
it could and was used
for propaganda purposes in some sense. Yeah,
I think that's right. I need. The other thing
that we can see, even building on top of that
is that there are quite similar rhetorics
around new technologies, which, which even
brings us up to the Internet today. So you
can see with radio for example, initially
that sort of utopian rhetoric, it's going
to be the savior of the nation. That's true
in Germany, in Britain, in the U S as well.
It's going to bring people together. It's
going to make a community out of these fractured
societies where industrialization and sort
of pull people apart. So initially it's really
utopian rhetoric about what radio can do.
And then in the 1930s when miscellany in Italy
or Hitler in Germany are using radio to try
and broadcast fascist propaganda within their
countries and also outside of it. Now radio
seems to be a tool of demagogues and dictators.
So we, we see this move from Utopian hopes
into dystopian nightmares and then often settling
somewhere in between a recognition that technology
is neither our savior, nor is it our devil.
It's what we as humans make of it that matters
most. Is there or are there ways in which
the sort of role and positioning of Fox News
in the United States today have a parallels
or analogs to what you talk about in the book
from the Early 20th Century? So there, there
is some analog I think so there's, there's
one a right wing media magnate, a man called
Alfred who can bag who creates a whole vertically
integrated media empire. So he has everything
from the paper companies that are manufacturing
the paper for his newspapers, newspapers,
advertising agencies, uh, his own news agency.
And then he also ends up buying at the biggest
film company in Weimar, Germany, which was
a very big film industry at that point.
The one that made films like Fritz Lang's
metropolis for example, and who can both company
does best some resemblance as to fox in the
sense that he basically asked his editors
to push what he calls that sort of nationalist
point of view, something that's more or talk
talking. He has a particular political party
that he supports, but he doesn't want the
editor to necessarily just support that party
but just have a particular point of view.
Um, and ironically what ends up happening
is the amount of support for his right wing
party drops. Uh, but much more support is
created for Hitler. So sort of out maneuvered
in many ways because people don't vote as
his newspapers tell them to, they actually
vote further to the right. And I think there
are some parallels to the way that Fox support
certain candidates in the primaries for the
2016 election. Then it ends up being Donald
Trump who actually gets the boat, who's not
necessarily the candidate putting forward
the views that Fox News would have represented
at that point. But that Fox also makes sense
accommodations with Trump. Yeah, that's interesting
because I've been reminding my audience that
early in the 2016 primary Fox was actually
not behind Donald Trump. And in fact there
were some pretty high profile conflicts between
Trump and Fox News at a certain point. And
I don't know if it's when Fox realized that
Trump had the momentum
or what exactly pushed it over the edge. Fox
did become very pro Trump and, and sort of
got to where it was over the last couple of
years. But I also believe that if the continued
polling trouble, uh, is very visible for Donald
Trump. And it seems as though he might lose
in 2020 I don't think Fox News will necessarily
stick with him. I mean they are decidedly
right wing and their funders impose that they
must continue to push a right wing agenda.
But I don't actually think that it's about
Donald Trump's specifically. And I wouldn't
be surprised to see that change.
Right. And it's, it's also about bottom lines.
I mean it is, it is a commercial profit television,
right? It's full profit. And if your advertisers
are withdrawing their support, and I think
that actually brings us right back to the
beginning of our conversation about published
versus public opinion. So opinion poll are
taken as the main sort of proxy for public
opinion. And if those fall below a certain
point and if Fox sees its viewership drop
and the number of advertisers drop, that could
certainly lead to different perspectives being
shown on Fox. Now moving away from being right
wing, I doubt it, but changing some of those
perspectives, I think it's, it's not impossible
and you're quite right to remind people of
that 2016 moment where Fox makes certain decisions
and, and doesn't necessarily support, uh,
Trump wholeheartedly at all. When you look
back at the earlier broadcast, they were pushing
other candidates like Ted Cruz.
A lot of what we've been discussing today
is from the book news from Germany, the competition
to control world communications 1900 to 1945.
We've of course been speaking with the book's
author, Dr Heidi Toric, who's an assistant
professor of yeah,
international history at the University of
British Columbia. Heidi, so great to talk
to you today. I appreciate your time. Thanks
so much for having me.